what do you guys want in an entrepreneur
coffee shop
[Music]
happy weekend everybody hoping been
having an amazing one Nina's happy one
of the things that I've been thinking
about is starting an entrepreneur cafe a
place destination place for
entrepreneurs to come to and work and be
surrounded by an amazing environment
where there's entrepreneur videos
happening and business plans to look at
and quotes from the wall and stories and
just a home for entrepreneurs were cats
we don't just have to go to you know in
starbucks I like Starbucks but real
place for entrepreneurs and so part of
our plan here is I want to check out
different independent coffee shops in
Toronto to get a sense of what they're
doing that might be different than just
going to a chain store if you get some
inspiration for my future Top Chef check
it out believe or off to a good start
here we are same genes copy bud
I'm back on the street now they don't
have a bathroom Nina needs to go to the
bathroom we'll see if they go find
someplace to go to the bathroom so we
can go back and have some coffee so
first lesson in having my own cafe is we
need to make sure this bathroom is close
by check back success Nina feels better
but are dressed I should have the
bathroom as well as the cafe Oh cafes
are quite type of restaurant Nina feels
happier the bladders that is empty ready
to fill it up with some liquid now all
right here we go take two
Nina's getting that cappuccino when did
the child I take anybody but in the
product photography cited this is ish
what he was going to ME ME ME Lena
filming for you to shine Osuna we're
showing in each other's is what we do on
the weekends down huh go check out me in
this channel got hard just like you I
love it I got it I bonded you don't want
my reaction first very creamy guys we
have no probably need the practice
billing itself a mess with it drop on
the top put some sugar I like the design
I like you exactly like the design all
right what do we say bina sad
it's okay they don't have fast know
about the staff I'm not being nice right
detail smiler I at all we don't I feel
like the main person does not know how
to smile that's not great for
introduction okay we need friendly staff
at our place friendly staff and washings
okay Becca and we should be more
comfortable right it's as big bench that
everybody just sits on there's no tables
there's no Wi-Fi no Wi-Fi nowhere to
like it's weirdly me back yes
uncomfortable you can't really stay
there it's like a takeout place almost
yes okay what else boring I high cycle
yeah we need more separation all right
okay and the light side not great yeah
it has natural light that was good
collecting natural light got some good
windows fun to be fun to be on the Main
Street and kind of look out and see
what's going on us those good the music
was not great yeah hard rock I guess it
fits an audience what's entrepreneur
music got to figure that out unison good
entrepreneur music pros this is the
natural light was good the copyright was
ok he sings 15 the display was nice okay
anything else
cash only holy cow cash only constantly
bothers me I might walk out of his cash
only place anyway my plate will not be
cash only okay however you want to pay
all right that's it guys we need to hear
from you what you want in an
entrepreneur cafe leave in the comments
below and I just might make it happen
for you hope you had a great weekend we
believe in you we hope to continue to
believe in yourself and whatever do they
get put to the camera you're one where
it is much love we'll see you soon